know how reject Nations Greg Alba Here I
am jonald we're gonna watch the day from
Cinna fix 10 best character
introductions of all time you see over
at our patreon we do weekly Q&A s as
well as TV show reactions for many shows
that includes attack on Titan just
finished season 2 my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham just
finished season 1 Riverdale and also
supernatural just finished episode 12 of
season 1 we're really almost caught up
and John does music video coverage but
one of our top reward tiers whatever
video your request we must definitely do
and today comes from Andrew a Dennis and
who loves Cinna fix like a mofo let's
watch this video first a side note I
think Cinna fix is one of the best
YouTube channels of all time you only
get one first impression and that extra
is why you have to save the cat
[Music]
uma Thurman killed Oh one of my
favorites if I'm not gonna be on this
list it's one of my most classic
examples of this panic reveal is what we
like to call the introduction by parts
you see their hands their feet their
clothes their wine your team everything
about their face it's a small montage
15,000 miles towards the money shot
it is our heroes but all the while
shooting this buncee tour of all the
important details that make our
character who they are and Jesus
strangers on a train
however for our first myth we've gotta
go with the one on the image from
Raiders of the Lost Ark it's a good pic
good intro Alfred Molina freedom yeah
sure
yeah character spring fully formed into
the narrative in surprising ways
radical run in surprising ways to wrap
us by the collar in Perales like a bad
Christian Bale Batman impressive
question Jones we're Ruby brought in The
Fifth Element the joke The Dark Knight
dr. Strangelove from well dr. strange
well in our number 90 John Doe from step
oh it's pretty late into the film too
huh well it's weird watching this huh
the team's better you haven't seen seven
by now you might want to go ahead and
skip board about 45 seconds because
otherwise we're about to mess up your
day okay
Sena these ninety five minutes into its
120 minute runtime with the technics
Pitts and Freeman not much closer to
their serial killer than when they
started when he just shows up covered in
blood you go the movies the poster says
80 percent of the weight sitting between
a cigarette and drink a checkbook and a
generosity telling the camera he always
wanted to be famous poly eating
particular breakfast Luke grinning and
his beheaded meters Alex sipping his
Malacca plush and the dude sampling some
half-and-half
all of these films I'm a thousand words
about their characters and distilled
into what we think better
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like almost Napoli shaded to write
a strong character by showing your
hero's whoa Hellboy literally save
together make know like Snyder's so
proud right Monica the same with angel
lines the same with the man with no name
turns out sergio leone's damn good at
these types of interests married
Redwoods drinking contest to delve
another great example of this as is
daniel plainview so oil prospecting
vignette
however for out number seven we're going
with Kombe so not in order to pose as a
peasant to rescue a young boy instead
Samer come meet yeah it's a great
don't do that man hello we had to see
every movie in existence we're with
Roger Ebert in thinking that this might
just be the original example of the now
pervasive tradition of the action hero
starting off the story with an unrelated
act Paris perhaps even the first saving
of it's also probably where we only have
an idea for all the iconic character
introductions that color the passage of
this beginning Western seeing is how he
drew so much on cool asawa for
inspiration is a brief foray that speaks
to both his capabilities and his moral
character you can buy it's coming
compassion sacrificed and violence to
quickly teach us about and make us like
and it works perfect comedy is a badass
for the ages and it takes us all the two
minutes to know it our next two slots go
to those I call our moments where a
character bounce into the story with a
week in a grin and all the chart and
crew that is unforgettable entrances
quintessentially classic play and we're
splitting his cans right up into the two
slots because we're dividing it down
gender lines so we can see how kind of
[ __ ] up the difference so like male
stars are introduced like this
[Music]
while women are objects it is a great
intro that's a whole great like opening
right
so we should see the introduction of our
biopic shadow pod is showing over the
shoulders while Lisa is showing
DIRECTV's james bond's effortlessly cool
lisa has us falling in love now we're
not doing the use of Menace objects at
school or the use of women as objects of
romance it happens in the world all the
time both of these are natural normal
things they're just occupied lots of
varied roles yeah what the hell man what
gives let us be vulnerable and
extractive it's not fair how men are
treated through the variation of sexy
beasts done alone a new hope star Vader
in Tim Burton's Joker however come on
who does this better than his Fritz Lang
with his murder
oh yeah that's why I saw this in the
theater a couple of years ago just for
the song culture
I saw here uh I think it's a classical
piece in the hall of the Mountain King
cool that is cool that is creepy
yeah it's Peter Lorre he shows up any
shadow posters for himself
yes he's introduced any vilest
mysterious way possible the bouncing
ball the dialogue what an entrance
what an introduction I make excellent
idea we want to watch with the
characters very approach to the screen
fills us with big scary reveal as much
as it's a long slow interns that gets
worse and worse the closer we get big
Henry to fit Silva from Skyfall in the
original track they're all
larger-than-life characters starting
small in the frame and then walking
towards us filling it with their stature
of course no one's ever done the slow
axial approach better than David Lee
which is why no choice but to give this
spot is Sharif on leave for Lawrence of
Arabia
Wow
to say is it wide expanses desert as
claustrophobic as a closet means iconic
cinematography has an emerging as if
from a mirage generating the heat of the
distance and creaking closer for what
seems like ages and then when it feels
like it can't get any more unbearable
his bedouin guide lunges for his gun and
is brought down in a single shot and
then more quiet
popping slows dismounts and only then
speech is he a bad man a good man a
righteous man an enemy that we don't
know but we do know you probably shoulda
waited revealed the character whose
reputation precedes who's been talked
about in a rumor and pursued it so let's
spit was by now more myth and legend in
our mind than a face a symbol of
something rather than the thing in
itself this is bill bill bill
Oberhausen hey big shadow demanded hurts
and definitely hannibal lecter however
you do know us you already know who
we're gonna pick harry line the third
man that is a [ __ ] in inter all friend
show me this movie I'm gonna save that
cat Harry
[Music]
if you ever do keyless maker of having a
hard-on for Harry Lime you wouldn't be
far off base with so much time dedicated
to rumors of his notoriety how the
actual man possibly bit up but that is
the magic of cinema sometimes the man on
screen can be larger and I don't think
it happens anywhere else better than
here first of all it's fortune ones that
is most machines in that case maybe it's
our rose-tinted nostalgic glasses
talking here but for power money we've
never seen a face that gives us more
boundless unendingly combine it with it
why do you think the music the camera
move and the classic third man camp and
somehow Orson Welles makes the rumors
low small we're looking at the
introduction that comes with a reversal
of expectations maybe we heard one thing
or anticipated something else but it's a
good one today was to know other than
Willy Wonka oh yeah your choice he
improvised this morning there's a good
choice or insistent opponent or
something unexpected that's where the
number one category is this a good
choice good category comes out limping
yeah that's cool this guy can't possibly
be a famous chalk with - look at that
lip
ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
gee oh dude yeah those are great ones
all the producers so what do you think
do you disagree let us know in the
comments below
come check out a biweekly movie let's
talk back on Facebook live Thursdays 3
p.m. Eastern after every episode when we
answer your questions and respond to
your comments and you should subscribe
for more movies
well thanks Sena fix that is a great
list there isn't a lot of Cinna fix so
much is especially the way they break
down their list I feel like they have a
really unique way of doing it I love
that they always explain what their
category is for what this this number is
going to consist of and then they show
several examples what they mean by this
category and then by dissecting data
analyzing it usually when they do their
list I rarely am here going what why
this one because they've done so already
he had justified it for yeah they've
done such a good breakdown different
examples of what they could put here and
why and then they go with why they're
choosing this one you're like yeah it's
kind of hard to argue with it yeah yeah
I really appreciated this list both for
that for having you know like a
different succinct approach to every
rank but also every rank gets an
honorable mention or three yeah you know
which is another nice thing and yeah it
almost makes it more than just it does
it makes it more than just a list it's
almost kind of like a film school in a
way because you're Pirie into a bunch of
different movies and how they all use
the intro but also what kind of
interests and you know all the different
approaches and I was saying here going
oh yeah there are a lot of ways danger
to characters aren't there I also like
the introductions that I think Tarantino
has it has become so good like I brought
up Kill Bill Vol 1
Indiana Jones is a really cool set up in
terms of like who is this guy you know
makes you go what's going on who is he
you and I think of like the opening of
John wick or the opening of Kill Bill
Vol 1 or fast in the Furious one what
happens there he like spins out and goes
shut that's the first time you see Paul
Walker
it's great it's great intro when you see
those like two intros I like when you
open up a scene in the in the middle of
a scene there's already damage that's
occurred so you're not only being
introduces character at a weak moment
but you're also being thrown into the
plot mm-hmm
pick apart the context right away and
see what it says about each character
and then what's gonna get clarified away
for you in a couple minutes yeah I know
they don't have any category like that
here I wonder what I'm curious as to
know what the team and Cinna fix would
choose for an introduction of that
caliber but for me that is Kill Bill Vol
1 they were talking about defining
expectations in terms of like how they
did with Willy Wonka that's not based
off expectation in the trailer but that
bill book they have to finally seeing
Willy Wonka and it comes out limping
just a regular looking dude and he seems
like he'll he's mad at yeah I think with
something like Kill Bill it's not really
the build-up to intro but you factor in
the marketing of what you saw and then
you start the movie you're like oh [ __ ]
the main the cool guy that we saw in the
trailer or a girl is now all damaged
yeah what the hell is happening right
here uh-huh
it causes you to raise so many questions
and has a sense of immediacy that I
really do appreciate a hell of a lot
well I appreciate it too the way they
handled the 5 & 6 you know split
together with the like here's the common
intro for a male protagonist and here's
a common intro for a female protagonist
and how they very much difference in in
my history and that's something that you
can even still seem to today
hey you'd lose count trying to keep
track of how many like googly you know
female like whip up into frames there
are oh yeah like the track up on you
know your strong male protagonist or
whatever and I thought that was like a
cool way to also tie in just like a
cultural context to the list as well I
feel like Michael Bay has really helped
redefine that though definitely yeah
every time Megan Fox showed up on screen
and transformers she was always in a
suit and you know conducting business
and in charge of a bunch of mana yeah it
was it was really awesome
well I'm capable I mean think of how
many cars she fixes in those movies like
you know totally showing off her skills
and prowess as an auto mechanic
you know and nothing else they were
talking about with their first category
with people getting ready we'll get out
their clothes their items before you see
the face reveal to properly introduce a
lifestyle
yeah chat in or American Psycho for me
it would definitely have to be Batman
and Robin when they're getting ready in
there both of them they're not only
establishing one character you're
establishing two one both of Batman's
nipples both yeah and in the supporting
close-up on the gluts and stuff you know
yeah the thing with Cinna fix here it's
like sometimes we'll talk about
WatchMojo and it's it's fun to like talk
about the movies they said or like what
I might have put in this category
instead but here like they do the
honorable mentions you're like yeah
those are the best honorable mentions
right this list I think I feel like kind
of safeguards you from just the argument
overall like you idiots you forgot this
movie yeah include so many more movies I
feel like watch mojo's lists are mostly
like cultural relevance and that's sort
of the main driving criterion so like
yeah having this people bore broad as
it's good and I really like they're
picked for Kevin Spacey for John Doe in
seven it cuz tell me at first I was
really fascinated by the fact that Kevin
Spacey was like all I do it if I don't
get top billing you know what Kevin I
think we might be able to meet somebody
I don't know who's even that much more
popular this I don't remember the time
if Kevin Spacey was so much more popular
than Brad Pitt and Morgan Freeman oh
yeah Spacey is worth a Brad Pitt and
Morgan Freeman set what they're talking
about like those abrupt intros you know
ranging even from like Chris Tucker and
Fifth Element for me I would probably go
with Emilia Clarke and Terminator
Genisys
that is an example of that kind of you
know come with me if you want to live
yeah bad as Sarah Connor edited and it
oh ma jizz and harkens back to many a
things and in that intro and I like
their pick for to Co and the good the
bad and the ugly turbulent moment yeah
there's one intro I'm not sure if it
entirely fits into this category and if
you guys have made it this far you can
tell me if I'm completely wrong Will
Smith and suicide Will Smith and Suicide
Squad when he's on there punching that
back yeah they all get that I was gonna
say Jason Statham and the may you know
it Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
because in the beginning of that he's
you know selling jewelry on the street
but you can he's like really charming
and funny but you can tell he's just
hustling the group then he eventually
runs away I feel like they gave like
honorable mention examples here that are
very reminiscent of that but the one
that came to mind for me of this example
was Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
which I which if you haven't seen that
movie that's a great opening also Johnny
Depp and Mordecai this category actually
kind of made me think of the original
spider-man for some reason you know with
the the combination of the narration
then you cut and this was Peter outside
the bus like slapping the side yeah he
is not one of the best of all the time
but the doom head intro from 31 is a
pretty gripping intro for arguably the
most memorable character that whole
movie were a billion Marvel characters
oh yes Tony Stark where these in the
the RV and he's drinking and he's late
he's like the pseudonym for their one
category the save the cat category which
is the risk if you guys are gonna save
the cat is if your sin if expand you
probably know what it is there's a
famous screenwriting book I've mentioned
it a few times here because so many
movies Coffee it especially if you have
an antihero character usually we're
gonna set up with a movie you got to
have a moment where they call it as a
metaphor save the cat I didn't realize
how boy I don't think that was the intro
I don't remember the first ha boy
literally save the cat ha ha it
basically implies that the character
does something to make them instantly
likable and especially works of the
characters and is an antihero of sorts
ya know cuz it indicates they've got a
code man yeah yeah I don't know like my
favorite filmmakers really feel like
they might accidentally do that yeah
sometimes movies are more apparent it's
so common and preservers another hardest
time wracked my brain for one right now
yeah every one of these so obvious five
yeah I there every movie every movie to
choose from like a good example I read
the book and I reminded out or I noticed
it I can't remember if it was the book
that pointed out or if I just noticed it
this movie with Al Pacino called a sea
of love and at the beginning of the
movie he's undercover and then he busts
a gang of people doing illegal gambling
he has this kid with him and instead of
arresting he just flashes his badge he
gets the hint to run away because he
doesn't want to arrest him in front of
his kid so you're like oh this cop
brought down the fun but look at him
he's like he's a good guy
you know seriously speaking they they
have you know that category of like the
shit's about to go down kind of intro
I'm not entirely sure if this one
applies either because that's funding my
sin effects or such a film school that
you're also trying to completely
understand sometimes what they're saying
not that it's like confusing but you're
also trying to really understand what
the rules are I kind of think of the
first Terminator with Arnold
oh he's not the very beginning because
he got some of like the apocalypse in
the beginning of the film but then when
he shows up you're like damn just like
he's walking everything he's not coming
from the shadows once he arrived changes
yeah
that's a good candidate I'm not an
expert per se but I accept it this judge
says yay or if if it's we really want to
go hard Courtney enjoy Genesis and one
of the other reasons that most sinha
fixes I learned often and I've never
really noticed this type of attribute
with a villainous character or any kind
of character like when they were talking
about Lawrence of Arabia with Ollie or
god of your party at Skyfall like that
longshot I'm like well like trying to
Rack my brain to think of other movies
it's kind of hard for me because I never
noticed that that's a thing that some
films do until they pointed out like
that's pretty cool oh you know
definitely see it see the thing is like
I know I wish you want to reduce our
reactions very slowly making our way
into frame and then by the 3-minute mark
[Laughter]
like I I know that I've seen a lot of
very notable long shots that make use of
that really tight and you know thick
depth of field or whatever but it's hard
to think you have of a specific intro
aside from Lawrence of Arabia hey that's
the movie I got to see but that just I
felt so much hotter just watching that's
the thing as you look in the distance
and and you can see the horse's feet
hitting that weird you know optical
illusion where it just looks like sky
yeah and it's so jarring to see this a
great shot and the one that they
credited Harry Lime Orson Welles in
third man which I remember watching that
movie my girlfriend to show me a few
classic films and that was the first one
she started me off with and watching
that movie I wasn't fully into it until
that very shot and that was my first
Orson Welles experience other than
whoever played him in Edward my first
operator I was an operable
okay yeah that was my first introduction
to him in cinema and the second he
showed up I was like some reason
instantly hooked it was amazing I feel
like a very under because I there's a
cool trope to do where you like build up
a character to see if you live to the
when you finally reveal who they are the
one that I think is never talked about
but but for me it's the only thing I
made this movie like work and where I
actually became invested that is
Leonardo DiCaprio in The Great Gatsby
that is exactly what cause there's so
much build-up and even it's moving so
fast and it's not really it's like this
doesn't feel like a good movie when he
shows up that's it it's like the movie
has a moment of clarity that second he
turns around with the glass is like the
perfect translation of this kind of
moment for the mouth yeah
because that's what's 100% what came to
mind yeah I wish they referenced it
because that's to me like I'm like wow
one shot that's who we did that's him
right there
it lives up to the hype yeah I've been
that better movie then yeah the number
one slot you know with Willy Wonka and
the sort of misleading intro
oddly enough I don't know if this header
no this is like a perfect example and it
kind of combines with the first one so
bring in the list full circle but I was
reminded of the movie elf and when
they're introducing Peter Dinklage's
character because they're building him
up so much is this like Titan of
children's literature and then they do
one of those intro by parts where it's
like he's strolling in it's like the
back of his head and people are all
turning their heads and stuff and then
he comes in the boardroom and you
realize he's a little person yeah and
you're just like your whole expectation
is completely rearranged by that moment
and so like while it is markedly
different and also hats off to Gene
Wilder because every time I see that
pratfall
I always think he's gonna hit his face
like he really had like the perfect
somersault timing but but yeah I don't
know why that was the first scene that
they came to my no that's actually a
really good example right there yeah I
mean and Ray Dennison thank you so much
for recommending this guy
andrew is a guy who lived he lives in
somewhere in Michigan great Minton great
Minton all the way from the Kalamazoo is
what he says right here and this guy's
been watching the real rejects for so
many years that I'm surprised we're only
now talking now he like when we first
started talking he was mentioning how he
was reminded me at the days in Tyrone
and I like before we ever became like
actual friends and how we would like
react to each other's videos
that was a weird way of communicating
with each other without communicating
yeah this guy is such a huge film buff
and I hope that down the road you can
make it out to LA maybe do something
with film do because clearly you you are
when we talk about that film enthusiasm
really shines that are the fact that you
love Cinna fix you've got to be a film
buff yeah so man out here working at me
but yeah it's the way to get on the
movie floor closes yeah much smaller
places don't need them in yeah but dude
thank you so much thanks for being a
part of our patreon page man and thanks
for this yeah Thank You Cinna fix and
thank you for watching guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon TV show reactions Q&A is love to
have you come up at Rajic today